before we get into game play we need to
talk about fashion because you were
giving us look after look after look
where do you get your fashion inspo from
you know what i get it from so much i
get it from anything from like mugler to
like just walking down the street and
seeing humans to like uh it's like
sometimes i really love a good dog
fashion show you know like dogs and
really cute like outfits and honestly
whatever i feel like that day it's just
been something that i've been able to
been able to express myself in a way so
every day feels like a different like
outfit for me and it never feels like
the same thing it's very eclectic
i'm also indigenous so last night seeing
the smudging happening like that meant a
lot to me as an indigenous person
because
so many times we're not put in that
spotlight and to have that part of our
culture shared is really important
because i feel like smudging is
one of like the best things ever so how
do you feel to be able to help represent
indigenous people and show younger
generations that it's okay to be
yourself and to just teach others even
though we shouldn't have to do all the
teaching because that's a lot to put on
us but yeah someone's got to do it right
somebody's going to do it and like in a
lot of times i think of it as there's
there's two sides of it is there's a lot
of times where we've talked about
ceremony not being filmed and that type
of stuff but i think big brother is kind
of a great platform for that for the
fact that like you're not you're not
doing it for the cameras you're doing it
for the people that you're in the house
with like the whole thing is about based
in like the people
um so for me i felt very very like uh
positive in the experience to be able to
share that with my host guest um and
knowing that that wasn't part of the
game for me that was just part of for
myself i always say like you leave a
legacy and like you have seven
generations before and seven generations
after and that legacy and who i and how
i represent that is all i want is that
for more of our community to be seen and
that we all have different different
outlooks and different conversations and
that we're not not every indigenous
person exactly the same but to represent
something uh like that was very i was
very happy to be able to do that
thank you for that that literally meant
so much
onto gameplay
what did marty have
like what did he have to gain by getting
you out so quickly that's a great
question could you tell me could you
tell me i have no idea i don't know i
don't know
i i think that like i didn't have a lot
of conversation with marty in the first
week for sure
uh i thought i had just about as much
conversation with him as anybody else
maybe i just didn't kiss his butt in the
first week i wasn't really interested in
like in creating like alliances right
off the bat i wanted to like have
conversations with people see where
people's heads lied see who wanted to
come to me
in that way
i don't know what marty gained i haven't
watched the episodes yet but i i hope i
hope he gained a lot because if he
didn't he's going home in the next
couple of weeks
he gains nothing
thank you
thanks i don't think he gained anything
i think it just sucked it's tough for me
you brought the life into the house i
was ready to watch you
create some drama like
and now marty got rid of you so was
marty on your radar at all before he put
you on the block no on my radar for sure
was like gino and her mom like her mom i
think is playing a very good game and i
and i knew that both of them were like
either we're gonna be physical threats
and also also just like very good with
like socially one has like rippling abs
that can like that like any person has a
hard time talking to and the other one
is like very good socially like very fun
a very fun loving uh marty i just kind
of thought of a person that was going to
make it in the middle of the show and
then eventually just get eliminated when
people got bored um so i was kind of
surprised that he saw me as a big pump
as a big threat
we're so were you supply surprised by
the two votes that were there to save
you
i just can't like those boys honestly
the thing is is i don't know if anybody
got to see this but i had i think i had
five votes from like what the people
were telling me but without seven votes
i didn't want to put anybody in a
situation that was going to
um like deter their game from winning
because at the end of the day like the
people you work with if you're not going
to win you want them to win right and i
kind of told them hey uh
i don't know if it's the right time to
vote for me uh
but i shouldn't have said that because
then i would maybe still be there
you had a emotional powerful moment
after not winning the power of veto what
was going through your mind during that
moment
uh i hate losing you're gonna ask my mom
i like would make her like whenever we
like were racing to the door or
something when i was a kid like i i mean
i would like cry if she ever tried to
get ahead of me i'm an only child i
don't like losing
um it's tough it's like you just have a
moment when like a cake like a wooden
cake
like takes away your opportunity to win
a hundred thousand dollars you know
um and also like i was really happy to
to have met the people i did in the
house so it was it was tough to know
that it was coming to such a quick end
who do you think is running the house
right now
i honestly think kyle is but i don't
think that's the best for his game and i
don't think it's gonna last for very
long
and who do you think could win it all
can we just say josh i just want josh
i just want josh to win i would love
josh or t to win they're both very very
lovely even though like i came for tea a
bit it was just i think that she's
playing a really great game and that's
the reason i had to be like
i don't know
who do you think is in an alliance right
now was there anyone you were suspicious
of
i know the boys are in an alliance and
i'm pretty sure it's with summer and tea
i haven't i haven't been able to look
yet but i i think that's what it is am i
right
oh i don't know
okay i'll watch i'll watch and and i
think the better alliance i think moose
has something to do with something that
boy is really shifty in the house
um lovely but very good with people so i
think he must have alliances
nobody wasn't in an alliance with me
just just friend just friendships
if you could create your dream alliance
with anyone in the house now that you've
met them who would you pick
um
i would probably pick gino's abs uh
then i really love
jason steph are really great uh are
really great shields in the game to be
honest and josh because i want me and
john i really want to be in joshua final
two
what was the hardest part about living
in the house
uh
oh that's a great question uh cooking
for 16 people is really tough you always
think that you have enough food and you
always run out um i thought i was really
good at cooking for like a lot of people
and then i found out i'm really not but
uh that was probably that was one of the
most interesting things i was like the
16 people is hard to cook for
that i was gonna ask you that what was
your favorite meal to cook
i so i love cooking cookies like one of
my passions i think it's the way i show
love and admiration for people and one
night i got to make uh my favorite
peanut butter stir fry uh for the house
guests and everybody really really liked
it it was it was like delicious all you
need is a lot of ginger and a lot of
garlic and you are having the best time
and a lot of peanut butter you know that
sounds amazing
oh it's so good i like think about it
all the time i just want to eat it all
the time
if you had the chance to go back into
the house and do it all over again would
you do anything differently
absolutely absolutely
for sure i would try to win that i would
try to win that pov for a while um but
more than anything i think i would have
just uh made like solidified more things
in the beginning i
i knew that was like the normal route of
going of going but i didn't want to like
give i wanted to give everybody the
benefit of the dough but then i brought
this big brother and nobody was giving
me the benefit of the doubt probably and
that that messed up my game but i'm i'm
very happy that i got to at least
interact with people in a really
beautiful way but i always forget that
there's a game play part of it i was
just like wanting to like make cookies
in kumbaya you know
were there any big brother canada house
guests like past house guests that you
looked up to and wanted to kind of mold
your game after before going into the
house
um i really like i really really really
love sarah's game from season three
and i i think that she played a really
honest game in a really like kind game
and i think that she might be
permastoned in the in that season which
i love that she was just like chilling
and vibing and i love that uh if i wish
i ideally would have played a kevin game
uh from season five
and really worked my worked my way with
my uh with my mouth but i did not do
that but that's what i was gonna that's
what i intended to do that's what i
wanted to do
and my last question for you is do you
have a message that you want to leave
your fans with because people were going
crazy on twitter last night so
uh
bring me back for all-stars let's do it
let's have a redemption season i promise
i'll do better i will make alliances
have conversations but still be the most
adorable jay i can be
you